Joe Biden is sending in the troops 1500
active duty soldiers are heading to the
southern border ahead of a coming
migrant Avalanche they'll get there on
May 10th just a day before title 42
expires and unleashes the floodgates
translation Joe Biden thinks the surge
will be a big effing deal it's a move
that drove liberals nuts when the other
guy did it of course but now the
administration is tight-lipped
and in 2018 just before the midterm
elections president Trump ordered 5200
U.S troops to fortify the Border
at the time Democrats and former
military officials and officers came out
against that saying they were being used
for political reasons how is this
different yeah so you know really my
focus here is on talking about what
we've been asked to do and and what
we're doing and while President Biden
sends in troops to deal with the
Overflow of migrants his White House
Press Secretary is trying to push a
bogus narrative that illegal immigration
is down more than 90 percent too bad for
her the ducinator was on patrol today
we actually deal with the immigration
system in a humane way you've seen the
parolee program be so successful it has
it has it has uh when it comes to
Illegal migration you've seen it come
down uh by more than 90 percent and
that's because of this act the actions
that this president has taken where did
that number come from it was I was
speaking he was telling us the number is
I hear you I'm about to answer I'm about
some people I'm about to answer you two
years if you if you if The Dramatics
could come down just a little bit so I
was speaking to the parolee program data
has shown us that it has gone down by
more than 90 percent oh yeah well the
spin doesn't work you can always call
people racist New York city mayor Eric
Adams is accusing Texas governor Greg
Abbott of targeting black run cities
with his migrant busing plan
000 cities in New York 108
000. uh Governor Abbott sent uh Asylum
Seekers to New York black mayor to
Washington black mayor to Houston black
mayor uh to Los Angeles black mayor to
Denver black mayor I cannot ignore the
fact that Governor Abbott sent migrants
only to cities with their black Mayors
and is undermining our cities all right
uh judge this is always gets kind of
infuriating when the race card is pulled
because it it's like just if you just
tried to solve the problem rather than
have to deflect but everybody on the
other side blames Joe Biden last time I
checked he's not a black mayor he's a
white president well he's the guy who's
letting them in but the amazing part of
this is that there is a the mayor from
El Paso who's a Democrat who is sending
them to Chicago but nobody in New York
City but nobody's talking about that and
I have to make one comment about Lori
Lightfoot where she says uh she's
shocked that many illegals who arrived
need food clothing and shelter is she
clueless I mean these are Sanctuary
cities these are big cities that's why
people are being sent there these are
City cities that say send me your hungry
and send me those who want to be
protected from the law but the thing
that's most really alarming about this
is Korea Jean-Pierre she comes out and
she says you know what we have reduced
the number is down 90 percent we are the
president is doing a great job well
she's full of crap because it's not down
90 80 70 60. in fact it's up 10 and she
comes up with some program that she's
able to rationalize that wasn't a part
of the discussion in the first place but
let's talk about the 1500 people are
being sent the active duty troops to the
Border last year in the 1.5 trillion
dollar Omnibus Bill Biden cut border
patrol by a half a billion dollars and
it was amazing that yesterday he was
talking about how great the Border
Patrol was he just cut them by half a
billion dollars and now he's saying you
know what they're doing a great job but
now we have to send more people there
but why are we sending troops there
we're sending them in we're taking them
off of anti-terrorism task forces we're
taking him off of a whole program where
we're reuniting families and we're
sending them in so they can welcome them
in and then release them this is a joke
but what do you make of This Dana well I
suspect Eric Adams would have liked a
heads up about the 1500 troops going to
the border before he threw down the race
card the other thing that all of those
cities have in common is that they are
all Sanctuary cities yeah and everybody
that gets on a bus knows exactly where
they're going and partly they want to go
to these cities because that's where a
lot of people can find work and that's
where their families are so that's what
is happening there and also why don't
they ever complain that the white
president isn't helping out the black
Mayors exactly whereas like they they
will they are quick to blame president
Trump who would have sent more money
right like he wasn't afraid to be able
to say like okay well if we if here like
in Chicago dealing with the gun violence
he was like oh you want more people I'll
send you some resources but then they
turn them down on that they this is a
federal problem to solve and the Mayors
are on the brunt taking the brunt of it
but they will not ask the white house
for more help they won't turn they won't
turn in that and the other thing is for
Peter Ducey he's like a calm cool
collected in the briefing room I I do
think that he deserves a little bit
either some humility from the press
secretary to say okay I was I was we
were talking two different things
appreciate the question let me go back
and reset instead she just says like
okay I'm moving on as if that's the
answer yeah you didn't like the
ducinator title did you like it really
right I I don't know I mean I like how
you spelled it I would have spelled it
differently yeah well our writers are on
strike so that's a problem uh you know
Jessica you can't invite somebody to a
party and then claim racism when they
show up isn't that what the sanctuary is
that what mayor Adams kind of did it's
like here's an open door but if you come
uh isn't he racist because they're
Mexican or Spanish they're Honduran
they're Guatemalan maybe he's the racist
Jessica are you defending racists
no not even a little bit and I hadn't
considered that one and didn't think
that's where you were going with it but
I'm glad that we got there yeah and
everyone is settled um
he also later on in that clip calls out
President Biden
more than any other mayor has any other
Democratic mayor has and he has done
this before and he's very clear about
the fact that the feds owe these cities
dollars to be able to deal with a
problem that they have created and I I
think that that's important I think more
Big City Mayors or mayors that are
getting shipments of migrants
um should be doing that obviously
they're coming because they're Sanctuary
cities and I think that Joe Biden should
allocate money to be able to accommodate
the problem while it's going on
um in terms of the 1500 troops versus in
2018 when Trump sent 5200 as you guys
have pointed out to me many times this
is a different scenario because we have
a surge of people coming across the
border versus in 2018 when the numbers
of people who are coming was much lower
and we know why it's different because
we had a three-year time out from covid
where there were fart we had title 42
and there were far fewer people that
were even trying to get into the country
because a lot of them were stuck in
places that they were coming from so
that explains that and to sending uh you
know Trump saying if you want me to send
people to your cities I'm happy to do
that he offered to send Ice agents
everywhere which isn't really sending
people that are going to be particularly
helpful to migrants well one if they're
here illegally that could help but but I
was talking about in particular was
about the gun violence and he said that
he would send FBI resources
so that's apples and oranges oh thanks
for that nice fruit salad actually she
just gave you the fruit salad
that'll be in a highlight reel all right
Jesse it's pretty good clickbait clip
away
Jesse uh round out this um this uh this
segment with some things I'm listening
to Adam say that it's racist for
Republicans to bring illegals Out of the
Shadows it's so stupid
permission to make an analogy I think so
this is like a lawyer complaining that
all these people are coming to them with
problems that's what you signed up for
you're a sanctuary City and correct me
if I'm wrong is the mayor of Martha's
Vineyard black or white I'm gonna have
to look into that de Blasio I believe
was white right definitely white Watt
and Rahm Emanuel was he white pretty
white okay
why wasn't Texas sending illegals to
these white mayors
I'll answer that question for myself
it's because there wasn't a
record-breaking amount of illegals that
were overflowing the Border back then it
has nothing to do with race Texas is
full
Texas doesn't even have a state income
tax and they're still paying for all of
these illegals millions of them the
mayor here is complaining about a couple
thousand yeah with more resources than
any other city in the entire country
that's ridiculous now I saw on the way
into work a illegal immigration family
digging through the trash looking for
recyclables how did you know they were
illegal you can tell
I can tell I'm a city guy and you don't
want me to get into it but I can tell
and it is the saddest thing to see
because they're not able to work here
they came to work but they're not able
to work here and the point is this you
have to be able to choose the people
that come into the country based on
needs if you need this type of person
you need this to put bring them in but
to just say yeah come everybody in and
then oops you know now people are
looking for you know a five cent bottle
that's not right and you can't blame the
guy down in Texas for that Joe Biden is
the common denominator for all of this
it's like a bad manager that doesn't do
his job then all everybody on the
staff's pointing fingers and bitching
about the other person but if the
manager would just do their job
everybody could stay in their Lane Texas
could focus on Texas and New York could
focus on New York are you you're blaming
Joe Biden because he was raised by
Puerto Ricans yeah yeah a truck driving
Puerto Rican Jewish people yes there you
go I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now